[Music]  Monday from the very first minute what's  she doing I need to talk to you to  people go home on a two-on-one mixed  journey to heal his heart he might want  it so bad that I'm trying too hard to  make it work and falls this makes me  very uncomfortable to pieces  my biggest fear height in Dallas and the  same thing gonna happen I'm starting to  question if he won't end up with anyone  he's gone all new bachelor Monday on ABC  Monday from the very first minute what's  she doing here I need to talk to you two  people go home on a two-on-one mix  journey to heal his heart if I want it  so bad that I'm trying too hard to make  it work and falls this makes me very  uncomfortable shoes I've been so patient  pieces my biggest fear heightened Dallas  and the same thing I'm happening I'm  starting to question if he will end up  with anyone he's gone all new bachelor  Monday on ABC